50.1 percent of women childless by 30
and both men and women are replying to
that tweet saying well good there's too
many people on the planet in any case
there's no sentiment more implicitly
genocidal than that statement so what do
you mean too many people and what do you
propose to do about that exactly Mass
abortion is that your answer it will
just shame people out of having children
I've seen people do that literally
there's a number of professors talking
to a couple hundred students and one of
the professors who was an
environmentalist activist type and he
got up on stage and shook his finger to
the whole young crowd saying that him
and his wife had only decided to have
one child told all the young people
there if they had a shred of ethical
decency that they would severely limit
their reproductive potential and I stood
up and said that I thought that was one
of the most appalling things I'd ever
heard anyone in Academia say to young
people but it's associated with like a
deeply rooted existential self-hatred I
mean hatred at the level of humanity is
like a virus on the planet that we're a
cancerous girl except Stein calls this
human racism